are you looking to optimize application
capacity amongst all the other things
global load balancing is definitely one
to check out while stay tuned to learn
more in this episode of get cooking in
cloud
[Music]
[Applause]
last time we talked about load balancing
on GCP including HTTP and network load
balancing there are a lot of ways to set
up a load balancer and back-end
instances to support something like
beyond treats growing e-commerce website
they've become a national hit and need
to start scaling their website backends
to meet demand one thing to highlight is
GCPs compute engine managed instance
groups to take advantage of auto scaling
capabilities this lets you automatically
add or delete instances from a managed
instance group based on increases or
decreases in load auto scaling helps
your applications gracefully handle
increase in traffic and reduce cost when
the need for resources is lower you
define the auto scaling policy and the
autoscaler performs automatic scaling
based on the measured load check out
episodes four and five from season one
of this series for more on auto scaling
but scaling global applications can be
challenging especially if you have
limited IT budgets and unpredictable and
bursty workloads you have holidays in
each country that spikes demand for
treat orders at different times on
Google cloud the flexibility provided by
features like auto scaling and load
balancing can help however Auto scalars
have some limitations there are five
major issues that come up with Auto
scalars the most common issue is that
your auto scale to new back-end running
your website isn't ready to serve your
traffic fast enough you might have
startup scripts that need to be loaded
before VM instances are ready meaning
traffic ends up at existing instances
that are over capacity
second issue is that some applications
cannot be Auto scaled at all for example
databases often have limited back-end
capacity only a specific number of front
ends can access a database that doesn't
scale horizontally the third issue is
that your VM backends might have too
little Headroom capacity to account for
sudden bursts of traffic and autoscaler
should include ample Headroom for
example you can set the autoscaler to go
into effect when your back-end reaches
70% CPU utilization to save costs you
might be tempted to set this target
higher like 90% but this can result in
scaling bottlenecks when confronted with
bursts of traffic like an
J'son campaign that suddenly increases
demand fourth issue is regional coders
if you have unexpected bursts in a
region your resource quotas in that
region might limit the number of
instances you can scale to and the fifth
issue is that you might have non-elastic
licenses when you use licensed software
you might have a preset maximum capacity
so you might not be able to auto scale
and run that software and more than
let's say five instances you can address
these challenges with GCPs global load
balancing solutions like HTTP load
balancing SSL and TCP proxy load
balancing first let's walk through a
recipe of how our global load balancers
handle bursts and traffic as you may
know typical load balancers use an
algorithmic approach to distribute
traffic to back-end servers like
round-robin where packets are equally
distributed between all backends
regardless of the packets source and
destination or hashing where packet
flows are identified based on hashes of
traffic information including source IP
destination IP port and protocol all
traffic that produces the same hash
value flows to the same back-end today
we're gonna focus on Google's global
HTTP load balancer for layer 4 HTTP or
HTTPS traffic typical HTTP load
balancers use a DNS base algorithm
serving two different load balancers in
each region failover to another region
is possible but it can take minutes
based on time to live or TTL
configurations generally a small amount
of traffic is still directed to old
servers well past the TTL this makes it
not ideal for bursty loads GCPs global
HTTP load balancer uses a different
approach traffic is proxied through the
Google front end or GFE servers deployed
throughout most of the global network
edge locations then the load balancer
algorithm is applied at GFE servers
here's how it works the HTTP load
balancer uses a special algorithm called
waterfall by region traffic that goes
through the load balancer IP address is
sent through a proxy to the backend
instances the algorithm determines an
optimal back-end by taking into account
the proximity of the instances to the
users the incoming load and the
available capacity of the back
in each region and zone the load
balancer then distributes traffic based
on available instances to add new
instances based on the load the
algorithm works in conjunction with
auto-scaling instance groups okay let's
walk through some scenarios when beyond
treats traffic load becomes too much for
its managed instance group to handle in
one region first let's talk about the
traffic flow in one region under normal
circumstances all traffic is sent to the
region closest to the user then the
following happens traffic is distributed
across instance groups which can be in
multiple zones if capacity is unequal
between zones zones are loaded in
proportion to their available serving
capacity with the zones requests are
spread evenly over the instances in each
instance group if an entire region
reaches capacity because the capacity
limits you assign to an instance group
the waterfall by region algorithm is
triggered and traffic overflows to the
next closest region that has available
capacity as each region reaches capacity
traffic spills over to the next closest
region and so on let's say you have
unhealthy packets and you need cross
regional overflow if the Health Check
sees more than half of the backends in
the region are unhealthy the GFE servers
preemptively overflow some traffic to
the next closest region that way you
don't have an entire region failing as
the region becomes unhealthy okay now
let's say all the regions you have
instance groups in our above capacity
traffic is then balanced so every region
is at the same relative level of
overflow compared to its capacity for
example if global demand exceeds global
capacity by 20% traffic is distributed
so that all regions receive requests at
20% over regional capacity while keeping
traffic as local as possible so how does
using HTTP load balancing actually
address the five capacity challenges we
talked about in the beginning let's see
how now that we've discussed how the GFE
and waterfall by region algorithm works
the HTTP TCP proxy and the SSL proxy
load balancers can overflow capacity to
other regions this means that it's a
good idea to use a global load balancer
over three
load balancers especially when it comes
to global e-commerce sites like beyond
tree app set use regional backends have
nominally lower latency but they can
become overloaded very easily for
latency in starting new instances if the
autoscaler cannot add capacity fast
enough during bursts the HTTP load
balancer will temporarily overflow
connections to the next closest region
as soon as back in instances are scaled
up in the original region new traffic is
routed to region closest to the users
again for apps like database is limited
by back-end capacity you can still
overflow traffic to the next closest
region when demand in one region is
beyond capacity deployed for usual
traffic needs as for too little VM
Headroom regional overflow still saves
money because you can either set up auto
scaling with a high CPU usage trigger or
make back in capacity well under a
region's capacity since overflow to
other regions ensure global capacity
will always be sufficient now for
regional quotas
if compute engine resource produce don't
match demand load balancing overflow
automatically redirects part of the
traffic to a region that can still scale
within its regional quota in the case of
licenses the load balancer can move
traffic to a region where licenses are
available you just set the maximum
number of instances to the same as the
maximum number of licenses on the
autoscaler if key to point out that you
do need a set of managed instance groups
in the region's you feel are appropriate
for your user base you have to also take
into account things like app licenses
and dependencies like database scaling
to meet the demand of auto skilled
website servers for more information
about GCPs global load balancing check
out the solution article by our friend
yen schoolers link below that's all for
today on get cooking in cloud hopefully
we were able to intrigue you with
ingredients and recipe to whip up a
resilient and performant dessert site
for our global fan base if you liked
this video and would like to see more of
this content don't forget to Like and
subscribe to our Channel
[Music]